[Music]
yeah come on actually can we help you no
Nina okay see you later
[Music]
Ronnie uncle Zeke he okay yeah let us
help you the trash bags in fact I think
we could come up with a solution for
trash disposal I'm getting old I just
need some rest we might be able to help
you improve your work thank you very
much
[Music]
uncle I think it's tight more easily
Bobby's absolutely carrying trash bag
size before head
yeah we need to comment upon including
so they can carry on
[Music]
so how long we have him to carry this
heavy trash bag we need to create a
special transfer disposal system I think
we can start research on this in the
library how about your robot that can
perform to be the same I don't think
we're capable of doing bad American crap
machine to help live this heavy traffic
I'm still using their hand yeah we can
use this is a leaf mechanism to create
the lifting system for the heavy trash
bags yeah
[Music]
Oh cervix the favorite first and then
I'll mark and song I'll do this easily
I'll mark out in general in designing
them I'll find the appropriate size for
the hydraulic new system to be able to
fit with a pipe
okay there
[Applause]
[Music]
something is helpful oh so basically we
used a sensitive mechanism to lift up
the platform okay and once the platform
is lift the petrol Battuta and the
rubbish will be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you